the mass effect trilogy might be known  for hiding loading screens with  elevators but Andromeda looks to fix  that I'm Tony and this is your fully  rendered GameSpot news update Bioware  revealed to game informer that Mass  Effect Andromeda will have no loading  screen when you step off the new tempest  ship onto a planet which the developer  says will keep the flow of the game  going smoothly that's not the only  change to the ship either you'll be able  to customize riders quarters and upgrade  your powers using a holographic  interface choosing a destination  involves standing on the bridge and  looking out at the Stars instead of  looking at a galaxy map overall The  Tempest is looking a lot different than  the Normandy Mass Effect Andromeda comes  to ps4 xbox one and pc and spring 2017  Bioware has also said we'll see gameplay  at the game awards in December so expect  new info soon to keep up with all the  Mass Effect news you're already in the  right place  you